[Music]
it's a good afternoon everybody welcome
to the session today really glad that
everyone is here hopefully everyone has
been enjoying Google next can I get a
pulse is everyone enjoying Google next
awesome great so my name is Amrita I'm a
product manager on the Google compute
engine I'm joined here today with Simon
and together we're gonna go through all
the content and demos that we have
planned today so let's get started
so before we going to go in let's kind
of see what we're gonna talk about for
the next 15 minutes or so the first is
I'm gonna talk a little bit about why
you should bring your Windows Server
well close to Google cloud we're going
to talk about some of the features on
the platform that customers really love
and choose TCP for that then we're going
to go through to customer journeys if we
see most commonly we have customers
faced with the problem of hey I have all
this legacy applications and I really
need to move off by private data center
into a cloud with minimal refactoring in
a very time-bound fashion so we're gonna
talk a little bit about all the support
that we have on the platform for that
and then there's a second customer
journey that is very common which is
around hey I want to move to the cloud
but I want to actually make sure that
the legacy applications or the
applications I have actually use cloud
services kind of have auto-scaling
reliability without me having to write
any code and we're gonna go and take a
look at what support we have for that
journey and Simon is then gonna help
actually put all those tools that I
talked about to use and demo how we can
take an application and move it in these
two different fashions in the end we're
gonna have Q&A and Simon and I will also
stay back so if there is content that
you do not see or have a lot of
questions feel free to reach out to us
so let's get started why bring your were
close to GCP specifically for Windows
Server we've been investing a lot in
Windows Server all the way since 2015
that's when we launched our very first
Windows server image
since then there have been a lot of
improvements specifically for windows
and sequels over we have a wide variety
of images to choose from both for
Windows and sequel different versions
different editions we've also built a
lot of features that are required for
enterprise ready workloads so
enterprises one support for clustering
they want to support for high
availability they want the methods that
work on premise to also work on cloud
and we now have support for that from
the developer site if you are a.net
developer on google cloud we've also
built in a bunch of tooling for visual
studios PowerShell and stag driver for
asp.net logging and monitoring in the
last nine months based on the customer
feedback we've been focusing on two
major areas migration and security for
migration I'll go into a little bit
detail as to what support we have and in
terms of security to things that we've
worked on is private IP support we heard
loud and clear that you want to make
sure that there is only private IPS on
your windows VMs and your sequel VMs and
that's in preview now going our public
very soon so we're also gonna very
excited to announce some features around
secure boot which apply to both Windows
and sequel server VMs now that session
on shielded VMs is the product is
tomorrow so please stay tuned for
announcements around that in the keynote
as well as a deep dive session at 11
o'clock so I'm going to go to three
reasons as to why customers specifically
for Windows love bringing their
workflows to GCP the first one is
performance when you bring your
applications with its windows sequel
server or net you're actually running on
the same infrastructure that Google runs
on your traffic never leaves the Google
Fiber even when you're going across
datacenters but what does that mean for
you that basically means that you get
superfast
latencies consistent throughput you get
all the improvements that we put into
performance to make sure that VMs put up
fast you can have a large number of VMs
boot up so customers don't need to keep
these pools of warm VMs ready and you
actually get the
of our Google Network for you so things
like we've had a lot of tests around how
our network compares to the others how
some of our products like GCS which is
Google Cloud Storage and Google compute
engine compare so there is a site called
cloud benchmark comm where we've
published some of these test results and
I highly encourage you to kind of go and
take a look at that the second is price
our philosophy has always been to keep
pricing simple flexible and try to offer
you the best price we've have products
like sustained use discount where we
monitor your workload if you're running
at steady state we automatically give
you a discount we have things like right
sizing recommendations that are
constantly monitoring your workload and
making sure we give you recommendations
that will save you and recommend the
right configuration we have features
like per second building if that is
something that you can use to kind of
get the maximum out of making sure that
your VM you pay for the VMS only up till
today are used one feature I really like
to talk about especially with windows
and sequel server when you're running
licensed software on VMs these licenses
charge on a pervy CPU so when you have
features like custom VMs and extended
memory you can actually get a lot of
cost savings so a lot of customers
especially when they're running sequel
server they want to go for the n1 16 and
the first bar over there shows you what
the estimated cost of running Windows
with the licenses is for a month for n1
16 but let's say you're running that not
because you need 16 B CPUs but you
really need that 104 gigabytes of memory
because your workload is memory
intensive you can actually get that
using custom VMs and extended VMs on a
VM which has lower V CPUs so if you want
to work with the 8 core 10 core 12 core
VM and not a 16 core VM you can actually
size that and that makes a huge
difference in the price that you pay for
licensing as well as the base VM the the
next reason that a lot of customers
really like is security so at Google we
have this policy as we trust nothing we
build a lot of purpose-built Hardware
to make sure that we have the full
history of the stack that we run on
Titan is an example it is a custom
security chip that provides route of
trust on every GCP device our
investments in making sure that we
detect vulnerabilities early and make
sure that we patch our host systems
without any performance or downtime for
our customers and project zero which is
the spectra or meltdown vulnerabilities
is a great example of that specifically
for Windows I'd like to repeat that
we've heard that customers really want
private IP support for Windows VMs and
that's available today if you click on
that link or come to me later you know
you can sign up and you'll have that
available for your projects soon we also
have some really fun announcements which
unfortunately I can't disclose but do
you attend the session tomorrow at
eleven forty to learn about secure boot
and a bunch of other features for
Windows VMs lastly reliability and I
mentioned reliability because as we're
patching hosts or us we are doing our
maintenance to make sure you have the
most secure platform we can do that
without having to reboot your machines
or give you any application downtime and
this is possible because we have
technology is like live migration so
these are some of the reasons we're
customers like to come to the Google
cloud platform they get the best
performance for the best price they're
guaranteed that the systems are secure
and reliable and overall you have a
great experience running your workloads
on our platform so now let's take our
second part right let's talk about a
customer journey so a lot of our
customers have been running their
datacenters for many years they have a
lot of legacy applications and they now
want to move to the cloud right they
don't want to refactor because they have
thousands of thousands of applications
and they want to move as is with minimal
refactoring in a very short time period
so the question is for customers with
such Windows and sequel server workloads
what support do we have foot in on the
platform for them so let's look at a
little bit about that one question I get
asked a lot and therefore I like to
address this up front is what flavors of
Windows to use
you know you support the latest favors
but we do understand that some customers
need to have their own time frame how
they upgrade so we also have support for
legacy OSS so in a you know with the
latest and the greatest which is 1709
and 1803 images we also have via our
migration tooling support for legacy OSS
like 2003 and 2008 are one when
customers wanted migrate they like to
know ok great
the platform supports this version how
do I actually migrate and over the last
few months we've been working a lot on
our migration story giving you different
options based on your scenarios there
are three options that I would like to
go through today one is the virtual disk
import the second one is our VM
migration capabilities through Belle
Estrada and the third one is cloud into
your the first one is really good if you
have a few golden images or a full
golden disks and that's the way you'll
want to spin up your infrastructure
on-premise and this use the same image
to spin up your infrastructure on the
cloud we recently announced our
acquisition of Bella strata and that's
adds a really rich set of capabilities
to orchestrate mass migrations last but
not the least we have a great
partnership with cloud and your and have
helped move many customers over using
their SAS based VM migration tooling so
let's dig into this a little bit more so
what is the virtual disk import a lot of
customers have what you call golden
images or golden disks now this is your
software your scripts and everything
pulled into one that is certified by
your IT or security admins and this is
what is your source of truth for
spinning up infrastructure on premise
and you probably want to use that seam
on cloud when you spin up infrastructure
there so we have a really simple command
line tool which you can download and
with a few simple commands you can
actually convert that disk into an image
in Google Cloud and just like you spin
up infrastructure using our images you
can use this custom in
to spin up infrastructure the same way
as you can import you can also export
from GCE using the same command-line
tool next I'd like to talk a little bit
about Val Estrada as I mentioned Veloz
Rada has an enterprise-grade migration
tooling and we're very very happy that
they are now part of Google and all
these capabilities are now available to
our customers within the platform what
is unique about the Velo Strada offering
is they have a unique streaming
technology now what this does is it
streams the virtual machine on demand
and you can actually have that VM booted
in Google cloud without having all the
disks moved over now in most migration
technology is you actually have a full
copy of the entire VM state all the
disks attached to it and then you're
able to boot it what this really gives
you is the flexibility of having that VM
boot up in minutes verify that your
applications look good and then give a
thumbs-up and continue that migration
story or thumbs down reboot start again
you can also do things like right-size
your VMs add different policies and
checks and then kind of continue your
migration journey so it gives you a lot
of flexibility the second thing to note
about Val Estrada is it integrates
really well with VMware so these fear
and recenter api is they've done a great
job in making sure that that works
really well so if you have Windows
Server workloads or sequel server
workloads running on vmware this
provides you a seamless way to kind of
move your workloads from your VMware
workloads on-premise to GCP we've had a
lot of sessions that probably talked
about this and I'm happy to go into more
details let's talk about our third
solution so we've been working with
cloud and your for over 18 months
they're a great partner and have helped
multiple enterprise customers move this
is a great solution if you're working in
a multi cloud environment so cloud into
your solution is really good and moving
from any source to GCP we have the way
they migrate is through block
replication and they have support for
all favors of windows as well as Linux
so you have three different options
based on your requirements based on your
workloads based on your timeline you can
move and pick and choose and move your
workflows to GCP we also understand that
in migrations you probably need more
support than just information about
tooling so we have an organization which
is the professional services
organization and this organization has
worked with many of our enterprise
customers to assess their enterprise
environment understand the needs of it
do a POC and then figure out what is the
best strategy to migrate to Google cloud
so if you go to cloud google.com slash
solution slash migration center you'll
have a lot more information about the
different plans available great so we
talked a little bit about Windows
servers we talked about the migration
tooling now let's talk about your
back-end so a lot of the windows darknet
applications that we have have sequel
server as the backend so customers ask
me what are the images you support just
like windows who you try to support all
flavors and versions of sequel server
and you also have to support for two
ways to license it you can use our
images and you can pay as you use or you
could actually have your sequel server
licenses brought in if you have Software
Assurance and that gives you an ability
to bring over your licenses through
licensed mobility when we think about
sequel server migrations customers have
different parts some of our customers
use the migration tooling that we just
spoke about and some of our customers
have different approaches to do that so
I'd like to talk about three approaches
so the first one is a lot of customers
just spin up sequel server VMs on GCE
and then they do a restore and backup of
their data from on-premise on the Google
cloud the second option is we went
through a bunch of our migration tooling
and if you have specifically if you're
trying to bring your own copy of sequel
server with the license included a lot
of our customers use some of the
migration tooling that we just showcased
and the last one is lock shipping so a
lot of customers try to do an
availability group they have a Dr sequel
server on Google cloud and they try to
use replication or log shipping natively
supported technologies and sequel server
to cut over so now that you've actually
cut over and landed your sequel server
VM on GCE you have your application
stack how do you ensure that you get
some of the enterprise gage features so
we have support for the two major
recommendations from Microsoft for
having highly available sequel servers
on-premise so the first one is
availability groups so you're probably
familiar with always-on availability
groups and we have support for that we
have it gives you like a regionally
highly available configuration you can
keep your sequel nodes in the same in
two different zones in the same region
or you can have them cross region the
good thing about this is it's a
multi-site failover clustering and you
really don't need a load balancer for it
so if you look at the documentation that
we have with just some simple networking
rules and routing you can actually have
the set up really quickly we have a
simple click to deploy template so if
you go to our cloud marketplace and
search for sequel server always-on
availability groups you will see a
template and with one click you can
actually deploy this and test it out the
second option we see and this is
typically for sequel server VMs that are
running before 2012 so a lot of
customers have physical sands they have
their databases connected to that a lot
of customers who have queries which are
cross database still want to have this
configuration for sequel server HEA and
the way to kind of support that is we
are now figuring out how we can build a
virtual SAN on Google cloud and then
have both your primary and secondary
nodes connect to it so the way we have
enabled this technology is by using
storage space direct which is a feature
supported in Windows Server 2016
what this feature allows you to do is it
allows you to cluster all the disks
attached to the various nodes that you
have provisioned in a Windows cluster
and present that as a single volume to
both the nodes on the system so this is
really cool it actually gives you a
virtual Sun at a very low cost it
replicates your data across these disks
giving you a pretty highly reliable
solution so we have support for that we
have detailed documentation and just
like the first use case we have a
one-click deployment template for that
too the third option is we've worked
with s iOS who's a partner and they have
a solution called data keeper and this
is very similar to the sequel server FCI
solution where they you can actually
have sequel server clustering without
the need for a SAN so they are also
having they also have a virtual sound
technology the difference between sequel
server FCI that I showed a slide before
and this is you can actually use this
for versions of Windows Server before
2016 so you know if you have some
compatibility reasons where you want to
have a Windows Server 2012 and still
want this feature this is an option it's
also a really cost effective option
because it works with sequel server
standard so if you have sequel server
standard and you still want to have a qi
this is one way in which you can support
it cool
so just to recap we talked about how you
can migrate stuff to google cloud we
talked a little bit about sequel server
and the different AJ technologies that
are supported on GCE last but not the
least people want to know about identity
and there are three ways in which we
actually support different Active
Directory use cases
the first one is customers have their
users and groups defined on their on
premise Active Directory domain
controller and they just want to sync
this to Google cloud so that they can
assign the right I am permissions and
give those users and groups the right
level of access on Google cloud and that
is a supported scenario we have a sync
tool that actually syncs users and
groups to
domain controller on Google Cloud and
allows you to assign i''m permissions
this is great because you actually don't
have anything from Google Cloud reaching
back into your domain controller
on-premise so it's a nice isolated
feature the two other ways to move
Active Directory is an hybrid approach
or an all-in approach as I call it you
can actually have a full trust
relationship between a domain controller
on premise and a domain controller in
Google Cloud and you can achieve this
via a VPN or interconnect the second
option is you actually move your domain
controllers to the different zones in a
region and this option is actually
better if you want a much higher
resilience and lower latencies because
the traffic is all on Google's network
and doesn't really have to kind of go
over VPN to your on-premise so different
options and different choices based on
your needs and scenarios we cannot do
justice to the full thing of that the
Active Directory but that was a session
at 3:15 and I hope most folks over here
attended it we had a customer Capital
One I see a few folks who are nodding so
we had a deep dive on each one of these
methods and we also had a customer
Capital One comment showcase how they
actually moved their Active Directory
over so if you missed that session
please look up IO 274 and or come and
talk to us and we'll help you get more
information there cool so last but not
the least if you're a.net developer on a
platform you have a lot of support so
you have cloud tools for visual studio
you also have support for dotnet core
both on gke which is our google
kubernetes engine as well as GAE which
is google app engine we have also added
some really cool features in stag driver
which allow you to debug your dotnet
code your doctor production code life
and Simon's going to talk a little bit
and show a little bit about that
in the next demo so I'm gonna hand it
over to Simon to demo some how we use
some of these tools so we're gonna take
a really legacy application
and just lift and shift it to the club
alright thanks um root ah so let's talk
about this demo a little bit so we are
going to talk about application which is
really old legacy application from 2006
dotnet framework 2.0 there is a
monolithic web front-end talking to
multiple databases and we are going to
just lift and shift this application as
is into google cloud so let's go into
the demo okay
so let's first see what our application
does so this is really a old sample of
e-commerce shop with the old stock you
can explore categories you can buy stuff
you can log-in
so basically yet another issue of
application so let's go into the Google
console and see that essentially what we
need to do is deploy it under compute
engine so we will have two instances one
of them will run is with the front-end
and another one will run cycle server
with all those databases now Ruta spoke
about the database piece quite quite a
bit so I'll focus on the IaaS piece so
let's go into visual studio for a minute
and this is the code of our demo
everything is available and you can
later on refer to to the full example
that we are demoing here in the
reference slides so I downloaded cloud
tools for visual studio and then if I go
into the tools and then Google Cloud
tools and show cloud Explorer you can
see different artifacts of our cloud
including Google compute engine so if we
want to deploy a new instance of is up
and running I just
do right-click and us p.net instance and
that will open a screen where I just
need to hit on this button and that will
make it work basically it will one-click
deploy the VM configure Windows and is
for me as well as all the networking
settings that we need to set up I can
use this cloud tools for some other
stuff as well it will make me a lot more
productive for example I can go into
firewall options and then decide to open
up some more ports for example if I want
visual studio remote debugger or some
other things I can just tweak it here
everything can be also done through the
command line or through the UI but this
is really very convenient way to do
things from within your integrated
development environment so that's our
first demo and over to Umberto great so
this was a really really simple
application and in a matter of few
minutes you could actually spin on both
the VM as well as the backend and have
your application up and running on
Google Cloud so let's kind of talk a
little bit more about this journey and
how you can modernize it more so before
we go into some of the options available
the question is why modernize and
talking to customers they come up with
generally three pieces of feedback folks
want to modernize because they want to
reduce cost and complexity if you just
lift and shift VMs as is you're gonna
save on hardware cost you know when
you're gonna run on Google create
infrastructure but you still have a
monolithic application you cannot size
it or change it up easily the second one
is pre speed and agility so as you kind
of saw the the petshop application you
kind of notice that there were a few
different pieces to it there was an
ordering there's a catalog there was a
product and there was a web front-end
now let's say your site becomes really
really popular right and the load
suddenly spikes let's see Black Friday
and people just want to buy a lot of
goldfish
you don't have the ability to very
quickly scale up or scale down you're
ordering part of that application so
people want to break this up into micro
services so they have the ability to
turn up and turn down things as the load
changes third is cross-platform support
as we go into the world of cloud
customers want to make sure that they
have the flexibility of running on
multiple clouds and in multiple
environments customers want to be able
to run their workloads on their choice
of operating system so these are some of
the main concerns as to customers have
and some of the motivations they have to
actually reconsider how these
applications are architected there are
many ways to modernize your applications
you could completely refactor you could
use more managed services today we want
to talk about modernizing by moving to
containers because this is one of the
most popular areas and we've got a lot
of feedback over here that this is a
really great way that customers want to
move their workloads and modernize them
so let's see what support we have for
them so today you can actually Windows
Server 2016 was the first version of
Windows that had support for container
so it had support for the docker engine
we have support for container optimized
Windows server images so just like you
have that whole list of Windows images
you can actually take an image run it on
take a Windows container optimized image
it has your docker images already pulled
for you with the right networking
settings and you can just deploy a
Windows container on it if you want to
go more cross-platform Microsoft
introduced
asp.net core or dotnet core technologies
and we've been constantly investing and
moving a lot of the libraries from
dotnet to dotnet core and this actually
gives you the flexibility of running it
either on a Windows container or on a
Linux container so if you were to kind
of develop on.net core and run it on a
Linux container you can actually now
move that entire workload on running on
GC gke or GAE
so gke is kubernetes manage kubernetes
service and Google App Engine so if you
absolutely don't want to do any
management GAE
is your better bet so a little bit about
why you should bring these containers to
Google Cloud everything at Google runs
in a container all the demos you see all
the all the different services that we
have they all our container based we
launch an average of about four billion
new containers per week and this has
really allowed us to improve the tooling
and our systems for managing these
containers at scale we've also been
contributing to a pretty successful open
source project which I think a lot of
you will be familiar with kubernetes and
we're constantly adding more and more
improvements to that as well as it's
great to see all the work that the
developer community has done to make
this project successful just like we
have support for Linux containers and
kubernetes is also a open source project
and a working group that's looking at
Windows continue our support and we're
actively involved in that group so now
let's let's kind of look at how we can
take our really really old pet shop
application and modernize that using
some of the tools we just spoke about so
I'm handing it over back to Simon so
this is just a reminder of the simple
architecture of our pet shop application
and now what we want to do is slightly
modernize it so in this case you can see
that we will try to expose some of that
functionality as microservices so we'll
still have a front end which is Windows
and is and that will work against three
microservices orders product and profile
those in turn will work against managed
databases so why doing that so you get a
lot of our architectural benefits from
me doing that such as auto scaling or
basically a lot of good scenarios for
doing as scaling with Google
infrastructure as well as very good and
easy integrate
with Visual Studio and a stackdriver
debugger which I'll show you in a few
moments so let's delve into the demo so
it's the same pet shop application but
this time it will work using a bit
different architecture so already did
some pre work by exposing the
functionality as microservices if you
alright if you have SP dotnet MVC
services and you want to move them to
asp.net core there is a relatively easy
path to do that if not you will have to
create your asp.net core services from
scratch and gradually move your
functionality over so I already did that
and in this case we'll talk about taking
that and basically doing
containerization so I added a docker
file I'll demo that on one of the micro
services but we need to do it for the
three of them so this is the docker file
you define the image at the base image
that you want to use and in Google we
support multiple asp.net core images for
different purposes so you can base off
of one of the images that we support you
define how to run your application which
ports to expose and some of the
environment variables that may be useful
for running this properly on the Google
cloud and then essentially once we do
that we need to build the container
image and push it into a container
registry so let's take a look at some
existing continue register images that
are already pre created so let's go into
orders for example and you can see here
that these are different images that
they pushed I can talk them and then
essentially the whole point is that we
can create kubernetes cluster which will
run our micro services in containers
using one of the images that we pushed
into container registry and then we can
get a lot of benefits of kubernetes so
let's take a look at some of
that so what I can do is run a
command-line cloud is decay shell so run
a command which will show that we
already have a cluster Burnett is
cluster that that a pre created I'll
show you in a moment how to do that so
this command can show you that we run
the micro services in pods and pod is
the minimal deployment unit for
kubernetes so you scale your micro
services in pods you deploy them into
pods and you can see that for every
micro service we have one pod up and
running in order to create kubernetes
cluster you can just go into this web UI
under kubernetes engine there is an
option to do that by clicking on create
cluster there are also other options
available such as command line tools
that you can use so essentially to
create the cluster you just need to fill
up the name of the cluster the location
the version of kubernetes that you want
to deploy and then there are certain
features that you can make available
such as tag driver logging and
monitoring and if you open this more
thing and then scroll all the way down
you can see that we are pretty a secure
offering in here because we can
basically define what Google services
will be available from that kubernetes
cluster I can do that for all the API I
can do that with full granularity so in
our later sample we're going to show how
we can use cloud debugger so for that we
need to go all the way down and then
enable cloud debugger feature and then
essentially we can click on create and
that will create our kubernetes cluster
so let's say that we have kubernetes
cluster up and running already let's see
what we can do this so one thing I can
do is just run cube city L get
deployments now cube CTL is the
command-line tool to manage your
kubernetes clusters for those who are
not familiar
and we are going to use this to talk to
our pet shop cluster that I already
pre-created you can see that we have
three deployments here one and one
meaning that we want and one copy of
each and we actually get one copy of
each but the whole power is what happens
when we want to scale so with kubernetes
you get this scaling capabilities
basically for free and it makes it very
efficient by taking care of all the
scalability work for you so you can do
cube CTL scale deployment and let's say
we want to scale order service and I
want to have three replicas so what this
command does it basically tells
kubernetes that we want to spin up two
more instances of our deployment and
kubernetes will do all the heavy lifting
for us and to kind of check on that we
can just run again the cube CTL get
deployments and you can see here that
now the desired and the current changed
to the street just like we asked we can
also run cube CTL get pods and see these
are the three instances that were
created so we basically just run one
single command and kubernetes was able
to scale our asp.net core application
really easy
now let's scale back so in this case i
just go back to one replica and we can
run get pods again and in this case you
can see that the two replicas that we
want to kill there and in the process of
being killed and essentially we'll have
one instance of every micro service up
and running okay so that's all good we
can scale with kubernetes and kubernetes
will will take care of the scaling
capabilities but there is more to that
so what if we want to handle resiliency
of our services
so let's try to kill one of the pots
which will essentially kill our
microservice and see what happens
so first of all I'll run cube CD l get
pods again to just kind of confirm the
starting state and now we basically want
to kill one of the micro-services and
see what happens once it runs under
kubernetes cluster so cube CTL delete
pod and I'll just copy the name of that
pod and you can see that it was deleted
now if I run cube CD l get pods you can
see two copies of that profile service
so one is terminating and another is
running which is actually very
interesting because what happens here
is that the one that is terminating is
that copy that we tried to kill so it
takes time until it's actually a gets
killed but then kubernetes was smart
enough to recognize that we desire to
run one instance of profile service so
if your service was affected and
essentially failed kubernetes will bring
another copy of that service back up
automatically for you if you have
multiple copies it will do that with
multiple copies as well so by just
moving to kubernetes with your SP dotnet
core workload what you your able to get
is full handling of resiliency as well
as scaling capabilities which is really
really cool now another thing that we
might want to consider is the feature
called stock driver debugger now this
feature currently is in preview but the
fact that we are running in Google cloud
platform with asp.net core allows us to
do the following so I'll open my debug
screen on the Google cloud console and
you will see here that this is basically
the screen where we can production debug
our application now it sounds like a
bold statement but this is actually what
it is in what this application allows us
to do is opening the source code of our
application
attaching the break points to existing
running application in production and
then inspecting the snapshot that
stackdriver will take from our
application if we heat that particular
caught path which leads to the break
point so let's try and see how we can do
that so in this case I can bring my
source code from multiple locations we
have integration with github github
bitbucket cloud source repositories of
google cloud as well as you can also
bring your own sources so this is what I
will do I'll check my local sources and
I'll hit upload now this is not really
uploading into cloud this is just
opening that locally on my browser and
you can see this is the code of the
application we'll try to debug service
called products and if we explore some
of its code there is this category
controller and we can just go explore
what it does but one of the actions here
called category and we can see that it
tries to use caching so if caching is
enabled we might use it otherwise we
will not use it so let's inspect whether
caching is actually enabled so that is
kind of modeling the real-world scenario
where you have something running in
production something happened you want
to understand what is the state of your
application without redeploying with
additional instrumentation that you
might want to add so you can just add
your breakpoints at the place where you
want to stop and now it's waiting to
heat that code path now how do we know
how to get into this method so in
kubernetes I did some pre-work which was
exposing all my micro services with
external ap so I created a lot bouncer
object and I exposed my micro services
externally so I'll run Q CTL get
services and this will return all of my
services running under kubernetes with
their external IP we are talking about
product/service so i'll just copy this
external a b from here and if we look at
the source code there is this route
called category so in order to reach
this code pass what we need to do is go
into this IP and then a slash category
so let's do that so this opens some
information which is categories of our
pet shop and let's go back into the
bugger so you can see here that suddenly
it shows all the call stock of that code
path so basically we hit the breakpoint
there is the call stack of what really
happens up until that point okay this is
the real application and also we we are
able to see here all the variables that
and their state at that moment when this
snapshot was taken so I can open up this
state and then take a look at this
cashing enabled variable you can see
it's zero which means false this kind of
gives me the idea of what's going on
with my application now all those
snapshots are really a powerful feature
and there is almost no overhead to run
that so you can run that in production
safely you can be sure that it will not
run on all of your CPU or memory the
overhead is almost next to nothing and
it gives you this powerful capability of
exploring your application state if you
really need that and then there is also
this snapshot history so you can share
this stage with other developers by just
sending them link into the relevant
snapshot and essentially gets into get
to know what's going on with with your
application alright so let's switch back
cool so hopefully we've demonstrated to
you how easy it was to just lift and
shift and Simon just demonstrated to you
some of the amazing capabilities that
just light up if you were to refactor
and move this to micro services on gke
a lot of the work was it was sort of
done and sort of explained quickly
because we have a short time but we have
a detailed set of white papers that was
that we wrote with one of our windows
partners Moe genic and they go into an
extremely detailed explanation for the
same application of how you could move
and the different pieces and the tools
and all the work done is actually
available the codes available so you
know you're free to kind of look at some
of the examples and see house we did
some of the migration there in addition
to that we'd like to also leave you with
some of the links so if you go to like
cloud or wind cloud or google.com slash
windows or sequel server we have a lot
more information and white papers and
best practices and we also have
similarly information about our
developer tools so if you we will
probably be sharing these slides after
the sessions so these are really good
links to kind of go and get more
information
[Music]